as far as breakups go this one was
abrupt and seemingly out of the blue
here's how Katara's energy minister
delivered the news that his country's 57
year membership of the world's most
important group of oil-producing nations
was coming to an end the state of Qatar
has decided to withdraw its membership
from the Organization of Petroleum
Exporting Countries Opik effective
January 2019
this decision was communicated to off
work this morning OPEC is made up of 15
countries it was founded in 1960 with
the goal of helping members benefit from
a steady rise in oil prices so just how
big a role does it play globally at
present OPEC nations hold almost 82% of
the world's reserves
katara by itself controls 1.7 percent of
the stockpile it might not sound
significant but for a country of just
2.7 million it punches above its weight
the decision to withdraw from OPEC will
enable the country to increase
production outside of the cartels
constraints but it's also being read as
a slight to the group's leading member
Saudi Arabia which last year instigated
a boycott of Qatar accusing it of
supporting terrorists Qatar's Energy
Minister denies there's a political
motive it has nothing to do with the
blockade okay the timing is if you look
at the status of the op ik if any
country wants to withdraw at what it has
to do is basically put in writing its
request or its decision to withdraw and
it basically withdraws in the next
calendar year Qataris decision to leave
OPEC may not cause major damage to the
group but it certainly calls into
question its reputation for putting
shared economic interests above politics
and for more on Qatar smooth to pull out
of OPEC I'm joined by Spencer well
director oil markets and downstream
energy at IHS market in London good to
have you with us
of course Qatar is
not a major oil producer we just heard
that in our report but does its exit
from OPEC have any impact on the cartel
itself it's it's inevitable that it will
have a some impact although I think that
that impact is is relatively small qatar
produces around 600,000 barrels per day
of oil opec produces around thirty to
forty million barrels per day so so in
terms of production Qatar is a a small
part of OPEC so a small impact but not a
significant impact but in terms of
reputation image or unity again maybe a
little bit but a couple of years ago
Indonesia decided to withdraw and then
decides to come back come back in again
I think it's I think it's logical what
Qatar is doing their priorities on gas
that's not that's not something new that
it has been like that for a for a few
years so oil production is not their
main area of focus and so I guess
they're saying they don't need to be
part of a VOC they they want to just
carry on producing what they can but
focusing on on developing more gas
you've mentioned gas I mean liquid
natural gas of course that is where cata
is already the world leader when it
comes to exports how much of a potential
is there well so so gas is a growing
market and the world's demand for gas is
going up the world's demand for oil is
going up as well but gas demand is
rising faster gas is seen as as a
cleaner fuel and therefore the the
medium-term future of gasses is looks
better are more optimistic than than oil
it's almost inevitable that the world's
demand for oil will peak the question is
is when is that going to be I'm
certainly if there's going to be a peak
in gas demand it will be a long time
further into the future than any peak in
oil demand all right it's been so Welch
there from
ih as a market in London thank you so
much thank you